la vache cinquante mille euros le cours
je me demande ce qu'il pouvait bien
enseigner à ce prix là en tout cas ça
donne envie d'être prof de philo a quand
même si on n'était pas satisfait on
pouvait avoir une remise et 99% où c'est
possible
est ce qu'il vous a déjà traité de
sophistes depuis toujours leur
philosophie ce par contre le marketing
le sophiste vous dire vous êtes tout
puissant vous avez le discours vous avez
l'amour des et le philosophe d'une pub
pour dire que le concept de vendre ou
qui produisait des slogans bon je ne
vous le souhaite pas mais ça peut vous
arriver un jour maintenant est ce que
vous connaissez vraiment le sens du mot
sophistes
est ce que vous savez qu'à l'origine de
cette insulte
il y à une poignée d'hommes qui ont joué
un rôle majeur dans la démocratie
athénienne
vous allez voir que la réputation qu'on
leur a fait est en réalité un juste il
est temps de réhabiliter les sophistes
je suis romain je suis avec aristote et
vous êtes sur mille îles et culture
générale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai compris qu'il fallait réhabiliter
les sophistes en lisant ce livre les
grands sophistes dans la tête de
périclès de jacqueline de romilly
comme je le fais systématiquement depuis
les quelques vidéos précédentes je vous
permet de télécharger mes notes de
lecture en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite ou sur celui
qui est dans la description puise en me
laissant votre adresse email alors
jacqueline de romilly 7 est une
essayiste française
une spécialiste reconnu dans le monde
entier de la civilisation et de la
langue de la grèce antique dans les
grands sophistes dans la tête de
périclès elle résoudre une énigme
les hommes de l'antiquité grecque qu'on
appelle les sophistes qui étaient des
voyageurs venus de toute la grèce ces
hommes sont aujourd'hui peu connu
alors qu'ils étaient très influent dans
la tête rayonnante du siècle dit de
périclès le vème siècle avant jésus même
les plus grands sophistes sont
aujourd'hui peu connu protagoras gorgias
hippias prodi cos ou encore 13 imac
ces noms ne vous disent probablement pas
grand chose parce que la notorité de ses
hommes a été affaiblie mais aussi ternie
dans leur passage à la postérité comment
est ce possible
c'est bien simple la réalité historique
et l'histoire des idées ont été déformés
les sophismes mérite donc d'être
réhabilité au moins pour cinq réseaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
alors comme à mon habitude lorsque je
m'interroge sur un mot je vais regarder
son étymologie sur le wiktionnaire ah
bah non tiens sophie ça ne veut pas dire
escrocs en fait ça vient tout simplement
comme le mot philosophie du grecque
sofia qui veut dire la sagesse ou le
savoir bah oui l'isf fils était en fait
au sens large des professeurs c'est à
dire des professionnels du savoir 13
imac avait plus renommé d'entre eux à
d'ailleurs fait inscrire sur son tombeau
ma patrie était celle des douanes elle
s'éloigne c'est une cité grecque située
dans l'actuelle turquie et ma profession
le savoir voilà donc un sophiste c'était
un prof on peut même considérer d'après
jacqueline de robbie que tous les profs
sont les héritiers des sophistes
puisqu'ils ont été les premiers dans la
civilisation occidentale à se
professionnaliser dans la transmission
du savoir
or qui dit profession dit rémunération
il sophistes était donc payer pour leurs
leçons et certains très grassement même
le tarif de 50 mille euros que j'évoque
en accroche c'est le prix d'une leçon
avec protagoras un des plus grands ce
fils tu qui apparaît de certains
dialogues de platon
petite précision c'est moi qui ai fait
la conversion des drachmes en euros de
déjà c'est très approximatif et puis je
ne veux pas vous bassiner avec les
hypothèses de calcul
je les mets dans la description de la
vidéo et si vous voyez une erreur
surtout dites le moi dans les
commentaires alors 50000 euros la leçon
de pottas gauras ça semble incroyable
impossible comment l'expliquer
le premier élément à prendre en compte
c'est que comme les sophistes était
critiquée et déjà à leur époque
en partie parce que leurs leçons et est
très onéreuse d'ailleurs et bien le
montant a probablement été grossièrement
surévalués par les détracteurs des
sophistes donc a priori c'est beaucoup
moins mais ça reste beaucoup alors
comment l'expliquer et bien c'est simple
protagoras était une star les sophistes
les plus renommés étaient des stars ils
étaient les idoles de beaucoup de jeunes
gens et ça coûte combien quelques heures
avec une star alors j'ai fait quelques
recherches en france la conférence d'un
intellectuel de premier plan peut coûter
jusqu'à 10000 euros
et puis je sais aussi de sauve son
personnel que si vous le voulez un dîner
privé
c'est généralement pour des affaires et
bien c'est environ le même montant
on n'est pas très loin des 50 milles de
protagoras et puis ici on s'intéresse ou
conférences des anciens chefs d'état
mondialement connu ça va bien au delà
françois hollande s'est au moins cent
mille euros
barack obama qui est très demandé ses
410 enfin bill clinton
le champion toutes catégories confondues
demande parfois plus de 600000 euros
pour un discours protagoras est un petit
joueur à côté
et puis si les discours convenus ce
n'est pas trop votre truc vous préférez
peut-être un concert privé de madonna
c'est un million d'euros pour quelques
heures donc tout compte fait la
rémunération des sopistes star n'est pas
si étonnant que ça par ailleurs j'ai
fait le même calcul pour des sophistes
moins renommés et je suis arrivé à des
tarifs qui correspondent à ceux des
cours particuliers moderne donc et un
scandaleux c'est sûr que platon qui
dénonce le business des sophistes
pouvait enseigner gratuitement et passer
son temps dans le ciel des idées lui qui
est l héritier d'une des plus illustres
familles d'athènes mais surtout les
sophistes nes croquer pas leurs élèves
pour remplir leur frigo
d'après jacqueline de romilly il était
de très bon pédagogue et ils
transmettaient des compétences de grande
valeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
socrates a des mots très durs contre les
sophistes ils les trouvent arrogant
puis ils dénoncent leur esprit
mercantile selon lui n'importe quel
citoyen pourrait bien apprendre à la
même chose aux jeunes gens qui suivent
les cours des sophistes je n'ai pas
évoqué l'opposition des théories mais ce
crac
à lire platon et l'adversaire des
sophistes mais si on compare leurs
méthodes intellectuelle eh bien elles
sont assez proches
en réalité la dialectique de ce crash
c'est à dire la manière qu'il a dans les
dialogues d'opposer les positions et ça
en s'intéressant sincèrement à la thèse
adverse
et bien cette méthode repose sur le même
principe que la démarche des sophistes
qui se met à la place de l'adversaire
pour s'entraîner à défendre sa thèse on
retrouve par exemple cette démarche dans
la technique de protagoras dit eddy
discours double qui consiste à soutenir
successivement deux points de vue
opposés donc fondamentalement les deux
méthodes
cette de socrate et celle des sophistes
repose sur la même idée la recherche de
la vérité demande de pratiquer une
empathie à l'égard des personnes qui ne
sont pas d'accord avec nous après se
gratter les sophistes n'arrive pas ou
même conclusion les sophistes sont
beaucoup plus sceptiques
mais d'après jacqueline de romilly la
proximité de leurs démarches
intellectuelles laisse soupçonner une
certaine influence des sophistes sur
socrate de là imaginer que secret était
un de leurs élèves
c'est peut-être un peu exagéré platon
disserte dans le mais non que ce crash a
écouté une leçon de produits cos mais
c'était une seule leçon et ils sont bon
marché pour autant pas secrètes étaient
en relation constante avec les sophistes
et il est fort probable qu'ils leur
doivent son agilité intellectuelle mais
tonique
d'ailleurs certains auteurs comme
aristophane se sont moqués de ce krach
en le qualifiant de sophistes jacqueline
de romilly fait alors l'hypothèse que
cette en raison de cette probable
filiation entre les sophistes et ce crac
de la confusion qui en découle que
platon fait réfuter les sophistes parce
kraft dans ses dialogues
bref la chose à retenir c'est qu'il ya
probablement un peu au moins un peu des
sophistes chez socrate et leur influence
et plus éclatantes chez d'autres grands
auteurs euripide le grand poète tragique
a par exemple été l'élève de protagoras
et de produits cos était moins cher
autre exemple
thucydide le premier historien
rationnelle aurait lui était l'élève de
gorgias de pro nikos et d'anti fond
jacqueline de romilly conclut plus
généralement de ses recherches
tous les écrivains du temps on était
leur discipline où l'on a pris de
quelque chose
les ont imités ou bien discuté il ya une
raison toute simple à ça il était bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les sophistes étaient des professeurs
mais il n'était pas que ça il faut se
méfier des catégories ce n'est pas parce
qu'on est professeur c'est-à-dire
passeurs de savoir qu'on ne peut pas
être aussi un producteur de savoir au
contraire même être un passeur de savoir
et probablement une position privilégiée
peut-être même nécessaire pour devenir
un producteur de savoir c'est d'ailleurs
le cas aujourd'hui de beaucoup de profs
d'université du lycée ou du collège
bref je reviens un sophiste ils
n'étaient pas seulement des professeurs
réputés
il était aussi d' authentiques dans ceux
où on les réduit souvent à 10 m de
rhétorique mais il était en même temps
des philosophes de vrais philosophes
avec des doctrines qui avaient une
incidence dans la réalité
en fait c'est même à cette dimension de
leur activité qu'ils doivent leur
célébrité
parce qu'ils ont diffusé des idées assez
controversé pour l'époque pour faire
simple ce qui choquait dans leur théorie
ce qui était perçu comme une menace pour
l'ordre social
c'était leur relativisme radical vous
connaissez peut-être la célèbre formule
de protagoras l'homme est la mesure de
toute chose vient à cette formule était
un peu le mot d'ordre des sophistes or
les idées qui en découlent sont
puissantes
rien ne peut être connue en soi même
tout est relatif
donc la vérité n'existe pas et du coup
la seule chose qui compte c'est que
l'interlocuteur crois que c'est vrai le
relativisme des sophistes menacé aussi
la justice les lois n'ont pas de valeur
absolue ce sont juste des règles créées
par les hommes et enfin la religion les
dieux eux aussi sont des inventions
humaines
alors ces idées attaqué violemment les
croyances de l'homme du commun
donc elle semblait dangereuse d'ailleurs
les sophistes se sont pris pas mal de
procès comme socrate
mais d'un autre côté le relativisme des
sophistes a également libéré les esprits
et leur a donné une perspective
fructueuse pour produire du savoir la
dimension la plus importante de cette
perspective c'est la promotion du doute
le scepticisme des sophistes a donné un
élan décisif à l'idée selon laquelle le
savoir progresse de manière négative en
invalidant des hypothèses c'est à dire
par essais et erreurs successives
or cette idée qui nous est familier à
grâce à des cartes et plus récemment
qu'un peu peur elle est au fondement de
la science moderne du coup jacqueline de
romilly estime que la doctrine des
sophistes peut être considérée comme une
des racines de la science de manière
moins surprenante
leur perspective intellectuelle a
également fait progresser l'analyse du
langage et les techniques de la parole
comme il était passionné par le débat et
qui vise enseigner l'art de gagner
ils ont donné une forte impulsion à la
rhétorique considéré comme une
discipline
enfin le relativisme des sophistes a
plus généralement nourrit les sciences
humaines
leur méthode dialectique a fait
progresser des disciplines dans
lesquelles il faut confronter
différentes positions comme le droit ou
la stratégie militaire leur intérêt pour
la politique et les constitutions à
alimenter la science politique
leur obsession de l'argument de
vraisemblance c'est à dire les réactions
commune des hommes les idées qui leur
sont présentés cette obsession à
augmenter la valeur des observations
d'ordre psychologique
puis il faut rappeler que le sophiste se
définit comme quelqu'un qui se consacre
au savoir or les sophistes historique ne
se sont pas cantonnées à la rhétorique
et à la philosophie
ils ont six touchés à l'histoire aux
droits aux mathématiques à la médecine
en fait il avait pour ambition une
ambition un peu délirante mais une belle
ambition de maîtriser le savoir dans sa
totalité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si on écoute un détracteur des sophistes
ils défendent est le mensonge une
égalité
le vol l'injustice l'athéisme le
désordre
bref le relativisme détruisez tout sur
leur passage puisque l'homme est la
mesure de toute chose
rien n'a de valeur dans l'absolu rien
est interdite et tout fout le camp c'est
un peu un mai 68 de la tène de périclès
non je plaisante mais il ya de ça bon eh
bien ce prétendu immoralisme des
sophistes c'est une caricature
ils n'ont pas supprimé toute morale ils
ont en réalité proposer une autre morale
une morale trag matic
qu'est ce qui est important pour les
sophistes qu'est ce qui fonde les
valeurs en lesquelles il croit qu'elle
est le critère qui nous dit ce qu'il
faut préférer est ce qu'il faut refuser
ce critère c'est l'utilité les sophistes
ont substitué l'utilité à la vérité dans
cette perspective une opinion est
supérieure à une autre
si elles se traduisent dans la réalité
par des bénéfices supérieurs ou par des
inconvénients moindre l'autre opinion
l'homme qui incarne cette sagesse c'est
le médecin dans l'exercice de sa
profession le médecin évalue ses idées
en fonction de l'effet concret qu'elles
sont susceptibles de produire chez le
malade pour les sophistes l'homme
intérêt à s'inspirer du médecin il doit
privilégier les idées qui le met lui
mais aussi autrui dans de meilleures
dispositions
or cette morale se transpose facilement
à celle de la cité toute idée une
solution qui contribuent davantage à un
thème commun a plus de valeur qu'une
autre et c'est comme ça que les
sophistes légitime la justice les
institutions politiques et même les
dieux dans la mesure où il crée du lien
entre les hommes alors qu'on fait d'eux
les apôtres du chaos les sophistes
valoriser en réalité la bonne entente
entre les citoyens et la paix intérieure
il considérait même que c'est la vie
collective qui fera pénétrer en
l'individu les vertus qui lui sont
favorables
en d'autres termes il faut protéger la
vie sociale parce que la société et le
milieu particulier
qui rend l'homme vertueux est loin de
l'apologie de la guerre civile
le relativisme des sophistes débouche
donc sur une morale une morale certes
pragmatique mais une morale quand même
une morale bien réel si réel que les
sophistes passé même pour démettre de
marins les sophistes des maîtres de
morale comment c'est possible c'est la
principale raison de les réhabiliter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à ce stade vous l'avez compris c'est une
caricature des sophistes que l'on nous
sert platon dont la fortune familiale le
protège les intérêts bassement
matérielles nous les présente par la
bouche de ce krach comme des escrocs sur
le plan du savoir on les réduit à des
maîtres de rhétorique sans scrupules sur
le plan moral enfin leurs détracteurs
dénoncent leur immoralisme qui mettrait
l'ordre même de la société en péril
il ya bien sûr des choses vraies dans
cette optique les sophistes les plus
réputés donner des leçons horriblement
cher à la jeunesse dorée athénienne
certains d'entre eux se consacrer
entièrement au succès et moratoire au
mépris total de toute vérité enfin
d'autres méritait effectivement
l'accusation du moralisme qui a rejailli
sur tous les sophistes mais enfin c'est
comme dans tout mouvement il y a du bon
et du mauvais il y à des excès en tout
genre il y à des dissensions
parce qu'évidemment les suisses
n'étaient pas tous d'accord entre eux
non seulement politiques membres mais
plus généralement sur leur vision du
monde et même plus spécifiquement sur le
contenu de leur enseignement
alors maintenant comment expliquer la
caricature dont ils sont victimes
jacqueline de romilly met en évidence 5
cause
la première c'est le contexte politique
la vie politique athénienne a baissé en
intensité après le 5ème siècle et le
renseignement est donc devenu moins
nécessaire la seconde c'est le probable
court termisme des sopistes trop occupé
par le quotidien il aurait négligé leurs
oeuvres et sa transmission
c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas cherché à
maîtriser un tant soit peu leur
postérité
la troisième c'est leur esprit
mercantile poussé par l'appât du gain
il se serait trop spécialisées pour
finir comme maître de rhétorique la
quatrième c'est leur ambition certains
sophistes parmi les plus renommées
pris la grosse tête au point qu'il
véhiculer l'image de professeurs
élitiste préoccuper uniquement de leur
business qui n'en avait donc rien à
faire de la vérité et de la morale
enfin la cinquième et dernière cause
probablement la plus importante c'est
que ce sont les disciples de la première
génération de sophistes ce que jacques
une romy appelle les grands sophistes ce
sont donc leurs disciples qui aurait
vraiment forcer le trait et suscité la
controverse mais les grands sophistes
ses premiers professionnels du savoir
qu'ils venaient de toute la grèce
eux ne mérite pas la réputation qu'on
leur fait parce que sans eux les autres
les ce grade platon périclès thucydide
euripide aristophane sans les sophistes
les grands ne serait pas devenu ce
qu'ils sont
sans eux nous ne serions pas nous mêmes
ce que nous sommes
selon jacqueline remy parce que tout
l'humanisme occidental c'est à dire
l'idée que l'homme devient meilleur
grâce à un certain rapport au savoir
cette idée décisive ce qui est
probablement aux sophistes que nous la
devons
[Musique]
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo jusqu'au
bout alors moi je ne vous demande pas
cinquante mille euros
je vous demande seulement si la vidéo
vous a plus de lui donner un pouce bleus
et puis de vous abonner à la chaîne si
vous aimez la vulgarisation de la pensée
et enfin peut-être de laisser un petit
commentaire
je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
télécharger mes notes de lecture soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite soit sur celui qui est
dans la description puis en me laissant
votre adresse email si vous voulez lire
ma synthèse écrite détaillée de l'essai
de jacqueline de romilly qui est sur le
blog ou si vous souhaitez le lire
directement tous les liens sont dans la
description je suis romain je suis avec
mon fidèle aristote que je ne suis pas
mécontent de ne pas avoir baptisé platon
et vous étiez sur mille idées de culture
générale vous n'avez pas besoin de payer
50 mille euros pour vous intéresser au
meilleur de la pensée sans vous prendre
la tête
[Musique]